Sure that a mute currently audio settings. But stop video out. Let me Pc. For video settings button dropdown
top of five video series. But the top-down
open for this. Four- options. Report campus
top of five chat button test switching without virtual pc or launch meeting zoom links. Support English mainly to edit level. One click, open zoom meetings on the by click and launch, heading level, heading level, heading level. Two League privacy statement closing tab closed document window engage settings, engage settings, landmarks, search Demos table, cat button,
engage headings, landmarks, engage heading mana regions table. That Portal Plaza climbed up navigation meeting lists, with four items that one link virtual, the engage heading Stand residently join the depending level. You'll be explore heading level schedule, a meeting time list of one like a fully request type, user interview. Listen: Links device, type, Laptop Os Windows assistance and link toss, browser. Chrome, Listen: setting level two environment and in level email send mailing platform with Demo dot Com Batwords Timely Mobile thirty, four. Oh, by Lincoln. Well, thirty, four Space
tablet, about L. Thirty, four selected copy selection to clip, password, cavity mobile thirty, four, said mailing platform at demo comm
period comm period platform with Demo, when the L. A. Tf. Oh, Fda Dfo R. M. At D.
At M. At the emo period, C. O. M. Posing Tab closed document window program. Manager Microsoft. That check three hundred and five
more options for you to share a list of us, but search box and it double, or the working orpad editor.
Wordpad. Dcers are linked past it from click to top fab with them at Well, thirty, four home.
It's a
Klux Klan. I'm. With you with no forty, four
it's A.
A. F, A. D. L, E-m. O one, two,
three, four, blank, four, three, two, one, two, three, four o the four or pad dialog, don't save enter desktop folder realist. No sheriff. Let's just put top of file, annotate button, post, open apps, panel, more button, Drop the bottom button
this Year's Kelsey W.
Search box in it and made enter and boxes. A mail message list nothing but arrived at
navigate message. List to not fill the synchrony space. Nothing to arrived yet. The navigation message lists nothing to arrived yet still android synchrony space called on my own that your email nothing but arrived yet. Control my Content Jok Mail Phone delete by junk mail fender message message. List Nothing to derive. Yet. Hold it for desktop folder realistically. Dr. Button Button, Dr. Bottom, Stop, Cheryl. The news is currently new. This out. Let's say button the
the new. It's currently new. It's all plus a button.
He's he's he's a to you,
please.
He's
a new. It's currently muted out to a button.
It's
audio settings, but I knew it's currently new. The outlook a button.
The mood is currently muted out to a button.
It's
i'll see you at you.
It's like you.
Geza: It's a
all those that me with the currently emitted out to a button.
It's currently muted out to a button.
Me. It's currently a muted on those settings, but I mean it's currently muted out plus a button.
Stop sheryl plus this button for me. It is currently muted out to a button.
It's a I was to intervene
me. It's currently muted out to a button.
Geza: Yeah, it's Good afternoon.
Kristen: I just started doing some user interviews yesterday. So this is my second one.
Kristen: I'm gaze. Oh, hi! It's nice to meet you.
Kristen: Where are you joining me from? I'm located here in Toronto.
Kristen: Thanks. Okay, cool. I'm in Peterborough.
Kristen: Yes.
Kristen: Nice. Yeah, There's a lot of nice uh
Kristen: like touristy kind of activities here like
Kristen: water stuff and kayaking things like that.
Kristen: Very nice.
Kristen: I have to turn that off. Sorry. Oh, that's okay.
Geza: Yeah. I I used to be when I was there last time. It was a bymc event. So I I was there. But it was a a couple of years ago. But it's a very nice, very nice present city.
Kristen: Yeah, yeah. I've been here for a while, So it's
Kristen: It's okay.
Kristen: It's been good that I would like to go somewhere else for a bit, maybe.
Kristen: Um. I think this is off. I'm.
Kristen: I have this. Do not disturb thing on, but it still sent me
Kristen: a message, so i'm going to
Let's turn my phone off just in case that's
Kristen: I was wondering. Can you? Can you see me back? Can you hear me? Well,
Kristen: yeah, yeah, I can. Oh, wonderful! You're great,
Kristen: wonderful, and sounds good.
Kristen M: Oh, why is it not working? I'm: sorry. Oh, no problem. Let's take your time. No phone.
Kristen: Okay. This.
Kristen: If it says, do not disturb them. It shouldn't be disturbing.
Kristen: It's
Kristen: okay, Hopefully, that's okay. If it's not, i'll have to try something else. But I
Kristen: okay, So
Kristen: I guess Um.
Kristen: Let's have a bunch of notes from Kate about uh
Kristen: doing a demo. So um
Kristen: okay. Sorry.
Kristen: I checked the password and the username and the but I I didn't see any website. So I was going to use the paper platform or something something else. Yeah, we're gonna be using a
Kristen: and just going through. We're doing headings and the search function.
Geza: Yes,
Kristen: sounds good. Okay, it's fine.
Kristen: My is is not sharing
Kristen: just when
Kristen: okay, I think it's off.
Kristen: My My sister is sending me a bunch of texts,
Kristen M: Not the time. Um:
Kristen: Okay. So
Kristen: I think we need kind of like a concise clip of you like introducing yourself just your name and what your assistive technology is, And if you want to open up the fable
Kristen: uh login, I I guess. Did they give you like a
Kristen: No, no, I I just I just just the the the password, and the you and the username, and there there was no better. So I think maybe I have to. Uh, maybe like, use the the the default, the uh website, and then I log in. If this credentials
Um: yes.
Geza: Okay,
Kristen: yeah, yeah. If you go to the the fable App.
Kristen: Okay, um site. I can put it in the chat, too.
Sure.: using jaws, screen readers software
Geza: for a browser. I'm going to use edge, And my operating system is in those level.
Kristen: It's perfect,
Chris: a selection like I'm not making trouble Com. Slash.
Kristen: Yes,
Kristen: so
Kristen: I send you that link. It should go right to the page
Kristen: to log in
Geza: me. It's currently a muted output on your settings button dropdown. Should I? Should I go to the platform? Should I? Log in? I'm already logged in? But
Kristen: Okay, if you're already logged into it, It's like a guest account.
Kristen: Okay, Did you get a password for?
Kristen: Yes, I got the desperate, the password. This
Geza: it's going to
Kristen: to see if it's the Mini controls on your settings button. Drop the windows, and best of them
Geza: Google Project is no time
Geza: and microscopic folder realistic. The recent search targeted search or entrepreneurship of favorites are really welcome, selected, expanded one or two favorites document favors three new claim flavors our favorites level one log into fable fabric, level zero with virtual vesing. Your dashboard table
Geza: surveys zero. Seven of scheduled requests in your homes label. That's one of the learning floral cable or the the May escape.
Same page presented Linked navigation List of All right. This in the current page with dashboard
Geza: mit ctl, and your dashboard, your Bachelorette Banner region Multi-length navigation Returning Link that sip domain content settings and moral mana region. Skip the main content your dashboard label labeled as a linkcraft navigation region with current band. I have to log off to some four shirt here. Two hundred.
Kristen: Thank you.
Kristen: If you do that. Is it going to like mess up this thinking about Okay, So
stable with the wind or earnings back to a current plate link.
Geza: This is what it is.
Geza: We're from the licks label with your patchboard table or timely curtains. License, navigate. These are the main regions heading level one that's made me just. These are button collapsed spaces. So complete my profile. Link Red Link record additional link login with that link logouts and their billing page logged into the table.
Kristen: Um! That's for me.
Kristen: I do have it somewhere.
Kristen: Um, platform demo,
Kristen: I have the because I copied the best word.
It's a
Kristen: Amy. Let it invite it to me as pop up email like one. So one thing that is happening on the screen is um your like auto-complete stuff is coming up with your email Do you know how to shut that off
Kristen: if you can, Just for this. Oh, it's going down down the region label that well settings and moral like profile, One percent in favor. Read this button back, button, press in the Ad button log settings, but in the back button log settings. But in the high side bar button menu
custom my sidebar. But outlook, button menu, Microsoft office button menu, outlook, button menu,
but games. But to a certain value
Geza: it's
games. Microsoft. I would look at customer high, sending button menu
log it, new type, button, and log into the table table. But present search. Send this page. But for a Kilar read a favor for profile. One set main region emulated in validity as pop of virtual Pc. Or main region, and continue button in mainly required virtual log into the fable table.
Geza: You know what like I have only here just the just the feeble website.
Kristen: Pray,
Geza: audio settings button drop-down Stop, with low Let me button. And then my other website is here, just the just the zoom.
Kristen: Okay,
Kristen: that's much much more what Kate said to maybe get around this is, could you? I don't know anything about Microsoft Edge. But does it have like a like an incognito browser feature like
Kristen: August, disabled people.
Kristen: You great? Yes, Yes, yes, okay.
Geza: They definitely definitely.
Kristen: Okay, That might be a good way to get around
Closing Tab closed document middle for windows and
Geza: Um recycled inject and might enter the recent search file that for open feedback. Submit close to the app in the windows. Two hundred and twenty four, no private window, three hundred and twenty four. Enter, opening the tab opening. No, it's the recent search targeted surgery in control. Chip a favorite sparkle Level one login to fable table
Kristen: right now. I bring it up the the private window,
Kristen: and it is a novelty
Kristen: well done to virtual Tv. It works, it's not there anymore.
It was just showing, like your personal email address. So
Kristen: I don't know that in the videos.
Kristen: Um,
Geza: okay, it's it's It's It's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's
Geza: platform demo that that's one.
Kristen: Oh, dear, it's still. It's still there, actually. Um I can. But I already in private mode.
Kristen: Yeah,
yeah, it's just coming up like as a little pop up like underneath the email field. It just says
Kristen: it's.
Kristen: Yeah, It just says your email address under it. I can edit it out like It's not. It's not a big deal.
Kristen M: Um: Okay. So the the email is platform
Kristen: demo, dot com
like for demo period,
emulate it and validate it for memo com email must be a valid email. Address log into the table page log, into the table table in private tabs and let you see cursor
Geza: type log into the table table center. So
Kristen: you missed uh
the traffic labeled Maintenance Anding Level one log into the table and for your label at email
emulate it in violent reform email Com. Oh,
Geza: the Michael Period.
Geza: Oh, there you see. Oh, and virtual, D's an email that's ne about an annual button ever
Geza: main region and continue button email must be a valid email address. She doesn't accept it.
Kristen: Can you make me land?
Kristen: What an at symbol in between platform and demo? I think it's a it's a it's a it's a it's a it's a it's a it's a it's an at symbol in between platform and demo I think
Geza: and and virtual. This email was the Reality Mail, written in the new button. Enter log in the table table, loading page, signed in without zero, signed in with a virtual design, Virtual password that's facing from clip backward that it's only rolling moment, the
Geza: you only don't remember your blog, but center logging, button loading page loading complete smoothly in your backboard paper, dashboard table, same page, only graphic stable. Dashboard your patchboard, same same equipment, everything. It's a freely current daily project. Link. Learn, listen, Navigate cas or button to link the request on.
Geza: Okay. I logged in.
Kristen: Okay, awesome.
Kristen: And i'm pursuing down, down, down, down with crappy label that's more deprived of It's a really good stage dashboards link projects. We'll learn the
Kristen: projects noon with that navigation category button collapsed together in like the requests all to see um the main region adding level one dashboard, sixteen or a Saturday of sixteen or twenty. Request news reset the list of to light on, linked by dashboard, the linkcom, and with that setting level two reason back to a weekly wall activity.
Geza: My upcoming meeting setting level definition List of favor of scale, heading the table offers my request to the either of my request, request types of misparts. I will find my engagements, like my engagement, right in the top sixteen or twenty.
So what I did. I just went through the headings
Geza: we divest.
Kristen: Oh, okay. So that was the heading. So it wasn't just coming. Yes, so I so usually what I do when I even I, bring up it. That's a website. I like to just a little bit to get oriented. What is on the website. And uh and um weekly just I went through the headings. So that's what I usually do.
Geza: The pointer, The jaws is always following the cursor.
Kristen: Okay,
Geza: what I would say, like the pointer.
Kristen: Thanks.
Kristen: Okay. So is there There's no problems with having navigation on this.
Geza: No, no, we beheading. I was reading the adding, So
Geza: that's more setting level. One sixteen or twenty requests in the recent activity. I didn't live like a long activity list of my my August twenty, my upcoming meetings at the position Linux or it's a table of tail. That's labeled on links to my requests is my with my umbrella with us types of minutes at bars or the shortcuts, and one exactly the chart to add one to my access. My engagement site to my engagements, like combo box to repent the top that we're setting level one.
Geza: That's what I did. So I went through all of the headings.
Kristen: So when I, when I go through all of the heading automatically, and I'm. Then i'm at the last. I think the the pointer it jumps up on the top of the of the website.
Kristen: Thank you.
Kristen: Yes,
Kristen: I feel kind of bad now. So you're You're a little bit like outside of the camera, like the top part of your face if you want to be on,
Geza: go ahead.
Kristen: Is it better? I? I push down the the chair.
Kristen: When I first looked at you You're
Kristen: he's perfectly in for him. And then
it was not so. Thank you.
Kristen: Yeah.
Kristen: On the table.
Kristen: That's okay.
Kristen: And all right.
Kristen: Okay. So I think the another thing that Kate wanted us to go through was
Kristen: navigating by using landmarks or regions. Do you ever navigate that way, or do you just use headings?
Geza: No, no, I can, so I can use the cursor keys. I mean I can use the depth keys if i'm using the deb keys I can go the list, but the links by Link Nano regions hit the main content. Same page linkedin same page link symptoms table that portal positionally grab it navigated with current page with three items that one per day link
what projects
Kristen: we learned with that. So it gives me more details. What is what is on the website? Katharine button collapsed. Lincoln request on main region, setting level one dashboard, sixteen or twenty, or it was Reset Day's office made me in a blit company backwards list and setting level. Two reason that's lately well active list of Night, A August twenty, fifth, twenty, twenty link Screen Reader Research for Label. Visual point of labeled in a one.
Geza: It's been completed. August Twenty Fifth Lincolnshire has been completed. August Twenty fourth link roll over five screen. Reader: Recently, events heading level two by upcoming meetings. The traditionalist teams are intervened in the league of line. That's not about trees and twenty two percent setting level two hundred and twenty-two and i'm in my engagement site at Kamala last year.
Your dashboard label and private tab selected one of the
Geza: we at the settings of moral labeled Virtual Pc Cursor, the
Kristen: so I went already the top of the of the page, and would like me to look for something or find something, or in some links.
Kristen: Do you want to open up one of the links to there's some like compatibility, test demo
activity
with the forly current-page bachelorette projects. We learned
with that navigation has their and linkedin requests, all plus the main region, petting level one dashboard, sixteen or twenty or quid residents. A august list of two. I linked my dashboard link company backboard with and then setting level two reason back. Lately, while activists of night by August twenty, the link of life has been completed.
August: research for label these who point to label them alone
has been completed. August Negro has been completely obviously focused by linked to adding levels of upcoming meetings that when the teams are interviewed.
Geza: So this i'm. Ah all at the meeting, like a free with a heading level, two labeled upstairs Same but um upscale table offers specialized, believe, explored courses, heading levels in my with my requests combo-ending Level vibr request type combo box to lips this, either,
and in the bar the chocolate one that's access to the chart type one, so, three, four, five, and my engagement slicing Combo box collects this year. The condition List screen meter with every stream. Seven volts for this domain. Read the I made, read the I made, read the the main reason and
you can re-all this page controlled at the State the sentence of moral matter region. Skip the maincont label that portal isationally traffic navigation with a freely current base dashboard. The
Geza: So Um:
Kristen: yeah, no problem. There's a lot of stuff going on on this page. Actually, if you want to go to the projects, tab like beside dashboards,
Geza: your actual safelycraft navigation list of for your own current state dashboard
with projects with current-page bachelors
Geza: with the free items navigation link graphic label that board, rep your dashboard, Same link to navigate and list of freely current date stashboards.
It's it's a dashboard like it's like learn link projects,
Geza: projects, like learn What's that? Navigation? Catherine Button collapsed. Let's see you. You want to click on the projects, one
Geza: and the request. Let's see either. And but the navigation lists and link learn linked projects and write records, loading phase, locking level one by projects. You must have access to a broader sob. In requests you can create a new project. The rest of the existing projects someone to make you a member of their project. So we'll learn more about projects setting little two link Demo projects labeled Demo. Examples of how label can be used observerly create a new project, domain, region and and
project stable samely for a network list of freely cash only current link. Learn list and navigate Catherine and the linking request on the main region. Setting level one, my projects, you must have access to a project to create requests. You can create a new project. The rest of the existing projects, in order to make it a member of their project like to learn more about projects, heading levels to the links of a project playable Demo,
Kristen M: for example, Observer: examples of howable candy, news, Observer, liquid in the main region, and maintenance and maintenance and maintenance of that legal learning was time, access to a pretending level one by Project the
Geza: So i'm here at the my project at a level with my project. That's heading.
Kristen: Okay. Um. The heading to which is the demo project. One? Is that a link or a button that you can
Kristen: mainly the the recycling button collapsed, and the the maintenance level. One. My projects, you know, must have access to a project that Reiner can learn more about pros, and you must have access to a project degree in requests. You know what's time? Access to a project that we're in request for main reason learn more about projects linked open to the Tab
Geza: Demo project, setting level two links, penetrating levels and links Demo project table demo heading levels who only can about really learn more about projects heading level to a link demo project.
Geza: It is the link when it's a cutting level to the leak of a project.
Geza: That's a link.
Kristen: Okay, Do you want to open that one up?
Geza: And they're building page table, demo table tables and linked my projects linked by projects, greater link, current, page table, Demo List and Red Chrome Navigation meter, that main maintening level, one cable templating level to project Overview project access private and we get the project and i'll go to the table. Check out this project for examples of different request types on the label platform, adding level. Three members
open the table. Check out this project for samples of different request types. On the table platform, heading level. Three members add members Button,
with the four. Item, Catherine London Number Michael Stout Center call. Lauren got it. Listen. Heading Level three on the automations. Once you'll set up recurring requests, you will be able to edit them from either heading level. Two project requests search requests,
filter, search button, so I know. Still heading level, freely applied to accessible you in progress with the floor on the screen meter, laptop, slash, desktop screen reader laptops, windows and mediate listen scheduled for five meeting time on the scheduled for Friday seven-second delivery meetings list of to like a labeled Number Five will. It is thirty, four percent in the other interval setting level re link of talk like you completed.
Geza: Okay,
Kristen: nice. Okay. So okay, I am off mute.
I was talking for a second. It was not not off.
Kristen: Okay. So maybe on this page we can kind of
Kristen: focus on going through a few different things, because this is the only one, I think, that has a search
Kristen: field. So
Kristen: um,
Kristen: I think because you're slightly out of the frame on the first time I got you to do the introduction. Do you mind doing that again,
Kristen: and maybe like, go like, return to the top of this page.
Kristen M: Virtual, Dc:
Kristen: We can maybe introduce you again. And then do you want to navigate this page using headings?
Kristen: Okay. So I'm Gaza and I'm using jaws, screen Screen reader software. And right now i'm using
Geza: Microsoft Edge and i'm using windows eleven as the operating system. So
Geza: right on the top of the page, and I'm going to check out the headings first
cable Demo adding level one adding level. Two project overview project access, Private link at the project. Remember setting level three add members, but with the four items, Catherine Long, and then automations adding level three one single recurring requests. You will be able to edit some cutting level. Two project to request search requests.
Filters apply to accessible university adding level three in progress with the four-year-old screen Reader Laptop Slash Desktop Windows applied to accessible in the versus Talk Election Menu for Completion. Five Flight Rover finds offensive talk Election. Many completed reveal these documents draft list of one like on screen magnification. Listen for both time. Saturday's absurd telescope screen. Real research for talk, election menu for repent the top labeling level. One.
Geza: Okay, I check out the headings and then
Geza: I can the top of the page.
Kristen: Awesome. Thank you.
Kristen: Um. The one other thing, like some people use this thing called regions to navigate for pages, so it kind of jumps people from
Kristen: it'll usually, if it's coded properly, it should start at the heading,
Kristen: and then it will go to like the main content section, and then the footer. Have you ever navigated using the regions like that?
Geza: The agents? So I have differential properties
Geza: made reading. So the if I rescue that's the main region main region, heading level one cable Demo heading Level two project overview Project access private link at the project.
Geza: Main reason at members, but
Geza: search, request, edit. This is virtual. Pc. Cursor.
What about it?
Search requested virtual piece, add members button.
Geza: It's it's it's, it's, it's it's a it's a it's a it's a search button for I notes to all this button menu collapse and setting level freely applied to accessible university in progress,
Geza: and there and I press Q. Again
Kristen: applied to accessible University by Theicago Action Manual, completed five flags and list of two, like a laptop selected top mixed users within list of tonight on table double four boots, August, thirtieth but over five hundred and fifty-two collection completed with the for like laptops and windows and media a screen meter Listen. Completed on tune they all reveal. These are twenty design which is drafted
heading: Listen, Google
Geza: It on the center table, Demo labeling close time button.
Kristen: Okay?
Kristen: So when you were just doing that, was it? Is it like automatically reading out everything else that's like underneath each of the regions? No, it just jumps there.
Geza: Skip the made content. Same page link. No, it's a but it doesn't automate the
Kristen: it's got to make content, namely, I have to press. Ah use ah donkey! And a sort of the same page like sip domain content like graphics label that's what i'm saying, I don't like that for you.
Geza: We learn with an application region, and as a
done cursor in some time. Cursor it's, and then it's sorted to be
Kristen: okay.
Kristen: So if you just press the letter queue. Will it go through and just the name? It just will just go through the regions. But it doesn't start to anything by himself. No,
Kristen: okay. Do you want to show me how that works from the top? Just just only like going through the regions like I think it had. Um, there's like a breadcrumb one or something like that.
Geza: So right on the top of the page. So the first region
Geza: mana regions. If the main content, same page links to the main content. Same page links to the main content.
Geza: And I, with graphic label that's more graphical to
Kristen: navigation, meeting with the free items,
navigation meeting with the free update dashboards, link projects, click, learn, listen, navigation, recycling, button collapsed navigation region, and Catherine button collapsed.
Geza: So that was the end of the first region.
Kristen: Okay, that's good. Um. Can you keep going down the page by regions just just to show what they all are
Kristen: without the sea, like
Kristen: Catherine Button, collapse
Geza: most of the items. And here's a list with my projects.
Geza: That's the end of the second region.
Geza: We don't like the jaws. That's what it says. Brettler Navigation region, headquarters, navigation, and the
So that's the end of the second, the next feature.
Kristen: Okay, Do you want to go through the next few until you get to
Kristen: and the edit projects, and that's the next meeting. Welcome to table. Check out this project for setting level. Three members and members, but with the fourite Catherine, London owner, Michael Stott Center, call Lord Godplus, and ending Level three and information. Once you'll set up recurring requests and level two project requests Search requests,
Virtual psi filters button, search, button, sort by notes. To all this button menu heading level three link applied to accessible university in progress with the four items: Screen Reader:
But why so accessible? University heading Level Three in the talk election. Many of our applied to accessible University button collapsed, completed. Five Flag five test list of two items laptop. So that's Tom Mixing users list and wisdom to items. Label four bullets. August thirtieth, but with end compatibility Test heading Level Three link over Find talk election completed
Geza: with the four on the laptop. Select the windows and media screen mirror was then completed on two list of delights labeled, and a three-point-level Re-link Review draft with the one like a stream magnification within the
screen. Reader research for people need to point out any level of talk collection. Many, of course, are completed. The
Geza: with the four, like laptop slash windows, immediate Screen Reader List, and completed on Saturday stable demo, fable and private time selected close tab, button and buttons and buttons.
Kristen: Okay, thank you.
Kristen: Um. Okay. So there's also uh the search
Kristen: field offense page. Let's request that space to make me. I press the letter E, and then I jump to the search as the shortcut is for it.
Geza: I'm in the edit box for the search.
Geza: Virtual Pc. For filter button, and it says, Filters button
Geza: search button.
Kristen: Oh, okay, I can't see that right now.
Kristen: The page, I think, has kind of jumped down to the bottom for some reason.
Kristen: Yeah, it's still in there. Do you want to just refresh the page and see
Geza: the five profession page loading base top of my virtual virtual label, Them: Okay, I refresh it. Is it better?
Kristen: Yeah,
Kristen: Thank you.
Kristen: Yeah. Explain how you would go to a search box, and then maybe just just search accessible
Kristen: when you get to it.
Geza: Church requested the State's main region.
Geza: Okay.
So right time at the edit box.
Kristen: Okay, Do you want to? Just maybe type in just looking at the list of these just type in accessible and see what comes up?
Geza: It's it's it's a
accessible access.
Kristen M: Oh, sorry it's a Ccd: Yeah. My building is Acc.
Kristen: E. Ss. I ble
Kristen: accessible enter virtual Pc. Cursor clear button killed her button search button, short-side news, no search match, main region and main region, and no three match found the
Kristen: sorry. There's an there's an e at the start
the spell the tea
A. To request that it accessible
Kristen M: virtual Pc. Clear button, filter, button, search button. So I notes to all this heading level, Free link applied to accessible you in progress with the four items: Screen reader, laptop selection windows and mediate with then scheduled for Friday step. Second, delivering a talk election manual for like wrapping the top search button and the accessible virtual vehicle. Here, button killers button, search button.
So in my nose to hold this button, search button sort by cutting live in progress with the four items in progress. List of for Screen reader, Laptop slash that windows and media was then scheduled for meeting time and list of tonight and Fable Demo by August thirty, first, two thousand and twenty, with end user interview,
wrapping the top search requests, and it to accessible virtual Pc. A clear button
Geza: search requested and accessible, selected by copy selection to clipboard Virtual vehicle. Here button space, Okay, virtual basic filter button and search button, wrapping the top space. Search, request, and it's basement from clipboard search requested and accessible virtual declar button killers button search, button. Enter, search, button
Kristen: like I know. To all this button manufacturing level three link applies to in progress with the four items in progress with the for a screen Reader Laptop slash desktop windows, and Media was then scheduled for Friday meeting time on safe Confirm. Scheduled for flight. Meeting list of Cable University
Kristen: Raven to um Cable demo editing the search, request of space, search, request, and search requested and accessible virtual piece, clear button, filter, button, and search button, for I know It's petting level freely applied to accessible university
Kristen: with the core like a green miller
Kristen: before you searched. There was, I think, about five or six different like project cards, I guess, like in this list, and when you searched accessible Now, there's now there's just two, and it's only the ones that have
Kristen: accessible university. It's kind of a fleet that they made up
Kristen: it wasn't heading level freely right at the top table that wrap into the bottom, but lightly accessible, and there was any other
Kristen: like it did work, but it didn't
Kristen: notification.
Kristen: It was searching right like it didn't actually say that it
Geza: Yeah, Yeah, because it it didn't jump anywhere.
Applied to accessible university heading applied to accessible pro at your request-standing level, to apply to accessibility project and automations and in search requested to access the virtual pc cursor the
Geza: apply to accessible university setting level three layers, adding that freely applied to accessible university, the
and applied to accessible university. But why is it accessible University setting level for applied to accessible university, but rapidly the top level leveling level project overview members getting located on the project or applied to accessible universal flight to accessible university, and the like to accept in progress with the four, like a three meters
Geza: windows, and media isn't scheduled for for me to time. But they confirm list of two like on table Number five bullets August thirty, first, twenty, twenty, so one hundred and thirty-five blogs to listen in other interview. Heading level really applied to access wrap at the top table, they will wrap it at the bottom of light to a target like a cleaned five flagged by whistle to my laptop like that top.
Kristen: He's.
Kristen: Okay, Yeah, that makes sense, because there's two different
Kristen: like sections, I guess, on on the list. There's the filters button. Do you want to? Maybe open that
virtual piece, Catherine Button? Add Members clear button kil her button, enter filter options, label, Demo Label and Private Microsoft, and depending level. One filter options. Broker's wrap checkbox project.
Geza: The first is
Kristen: in the future unsuccessful. Um, Do you maybe want to just try? Ah, checking a couple of them, and then submitting it at the bottom and see what
that's a
cancel check completed, completed, scheduled, scheduled in progress and progress Checkouts not submitted so middle check out draft, wrap, Checkmark's notion brooks on status wrap, check out the
Geza: it doesn't matter which I will check it or or
Kristen: no, I don't think it. It doesn't matter. Just
Kristen: web check outs not yet. Space at the desk.
Geza: Replicate objects, rafts or military carts and objects.
Kristen: Yeah.
Kristen: And progress scheduled scheduled to complete cancel Cancels unsuccessful check out, and success providers for compatibility test checkpoints not yet compatibility, or in the user interview applied filter button.
Geza: So and then Here is the bottom, it says, Apply filters, and for main region filter, but is filtering by, wrapped, submitted in progress, filtering by rap to submit it in progress
filter button filtering by graph to submit it and program with the four right screen meter, laptop, slash, desktop windows, and media listen wisdom to like the cable demo, five, August, thirty, first, twenty, twenty, two, one, thirty, two, P. M. We send maintenance and main region and main region and maintenance. There are no headings on this stage
there are no, and there are no headings on this day. Main read list and August for a table. That list of can listen, and media with those laptops screen read with the four items filtering by graph submitted in progress with the four items filtering filter button,
Geza: which will be open. The same list of free uploading dashboards, linked to the linkedin list of two by the link, like projects, and it contains virtual these filters button filtering by with the for like screen meter, laptop, select desktop windows and media. Listen. Listen to light on table, Demo five, August, thirty, first, two thousand and twenty, two, one, thirty, two, P. M. Labeled with the weekend.
Geza: There are no settings on this page but it doesn't slows up as a heading, and with the laptops left. That stream is before I filter in my wrap to submit it with a four like three meter.
Kristen: Is Is it like I noticed it said. There is no headings on the page.
Kristen: Okay,
Geza: but it it No, it doesn't shows up the headings, but
Geza: it's also like on cable Level five. Also to with that mediate with those laptops with that, and then with the laptop screen release of four items, three meter
Kristen: with the four I filtering by grab to submit it in progress with the four items
Kristen: List of stable Demo five.
Kristen: I wonder why that's happening? Because there's also there's something that says apply to accessible university. And it was a heading
Kristen: two, I think, on the other.
Kristen: Yes, yes, on the yes.
Kristen: But it's not happening on here.
Geza: No, no. So what's going on, you know, like like Sometimes, if you don't going on the list, I have to use differential properties for the list. Short of it. It is Letter L. Right at the top with a different if chosen in this, and if it's choose up in headings, I have to use the letter age, so I have to use different different
Geza: a shortcut keys,
Kristen: but actually some some uh search engine is. It is the same. Sometimes some search. As soon as it's so generous it shows up. At least some of them show, but most of them they shows up in heading some of them. They shows just this right. What do you prefer like, Would you rather
Geza: me person? I like the heading more? Because when it's heading I can, I can go by heading by heading by the heading. But if it's at least no problem with the But I have to have a little bit more, so I have to use the
Kristen: all right, right,
Geza: So that that's the So it is when it's list. I have to read even the details.
Geza: If you choose. Headings, it's faster. But
Kristen: right, okay, Do you want to, since we're talking with the headings now, and this page is maybe a little bit messed out of. Now, do you want to start at the top of this and then go through.
Kristen: So it has no headaches on this page. There are no headaches on this page. It's not the same page.
Kristen: Oh, weird. Okay. So once
Kristen: when you apply the filters.
Kristen: Yes, Now suddenly, there's no headings like the page itself. Hasn't hasn't like visually changed much for me.
Kristen: It's all.
Kristen: Yeah, I don't know what's going on there.
So So what's going on? If I press and the letter that
Kristen: with the free items
Geza: with the four items: Screen reader, laptop, slash windows and media with a list of two items wrapping the top list of three items.
Geza: That's the different. But in this end heading. See, I have to you. I have to read the more of the details because it's list.
Kristen: Right?
Kristen: Okay, Wow. I'm surprised that it doesn't still have headings on this page
Geza: open's new tab,
Geza: stable demo label, jump to line, dialogue to escape
Geza: cable demo, adding level. One project overview, adding left cable demo editing, list
the label Demo Label labeled it as a
Screen Reader Research. We're able to be wrapped in the top. Catherine Button collapsed, and Members Button Hilder button. Search, but I know setting level really applied to excessive in progress at a level really applied to accessible in the learning progress of four items.
Geza: You know what happened when I refresh it, it's totally take out the futures.
Geza: See
Kristen: the
Kristen: so it's really interesting.
Geza: So you know what I mean like, because I differ at the page. So I I think it meant event back to the default.
Kristen: Yeah. So I wonder if that's a problem with the filter function, because it should be letting you use the headings to navigate once you use the filters, but it's not doing that, and you have to go through it by a list
Kristen: I this. Yes, okay, wow, Okay, interesting. That's really good. I I will put that in in the video clips that i'm making, because I you probably want to know about that.
Kristen: I
Kristen: let me just double-check my email notes. So sure, of course, I just want to make sure that I have everything that
Kristen: we need.
Kristen: Have you had any any problems with any of the fable websites or apps or no? No, that's good.
Geza: And many times I'm. Using freeball website and my platform. I never had any problem. No, no,
Kristen: that's great.
Geza: Sometimes it once or pass it past connection problem, but it's not related to the maps at it positive I would say like maybe zoom
Geza: or something, but but not uh the website. Do not find one time I do. I had to set the the time, but also I could manage it that wasn't a problem. So I never had this very, very serious problem or something.
Kristen: Okay, what? So thinking about like other websites that you have had issues with. What do you think is like
Kristen: Some of the worst, like the things that are the causing most headaches for you to like. Do some website, if it's very, very graphical if it doesn't set the graphics for if I can, if I can, My! Because it could be that it like in navigational, graphic, or just a graphic? It could it? Could. It could cause more problem because I don't know, like what is on the on the graphics. But, for example, if there is a video one, it doesn't
Geza: it doesn't say anything I don't even know, like like what's going on, and sometimes it more like when it's a it. It will embed it in the website, and I go to the website. I don't think I know It's not that. Okay, just jumping with my? So I know some something is wrong, right because because of the website,
Kristen: so it it could be like that. But, uh, those, those on my my major concern. The other things are are pretty good, so if I can read the headings the least uh different links. If there is no broken link that that's okay. So. But if it's not labeled, But if it's not labeled, But if it's not labeled that that could be a problem. I don't know It's a navigation button or something else,
Kristen: right? Right?
Kristen: So, having the buttons feel like properly. Okay, I guess that's very important, because if it's, if it's navigation, it's just play, or something, or or jaunty, or forward, or backward. Yes, it it could be if it if I don't know what is on the lab, but because if it doesn't say anything, it just says,
Kristen: All right. I don't know what you're clicking on. They're agreeing to.
Kristen: Yeah, that's the problem. Hmm.
Kristen: Okay, I don't think that I have anything else that we need to go through. I think it was just headings and doing a search.
Kristen: I mean, the search is working what except, you know like when So that's a different, you know. But i'm using the when I when I apply the filters, it shows least that's it right. So
Geza: if I refresh it right, it goes back to the depos, so I I have to set it up the filters again.
Kristen: Yes.
Kristen: Yeah. Okay,
Kristen: yeah,
Kristen M: I will put that. We'll definitely put that in the video That's Uh:
Kristen: interesting to go through
Kristen: the
Kristen: he's.
Kristen: Well, that's good.
Kristen: Okay.
Kristen: Thank you very much. This has been super helpful, and
Kristen: it's a good experience.
Kristen: Nice! How long have you been working this able?
Kristen: And she's two thousand and eighteen. Oh, wow, long time
Kristen: Long time. Yeah, Yeah, It's It's like four years. Yeah,
I was there from the beginning. So
Kristen: right yeah, I was gonna say It's a pretty. It's a pretty new company. So
Kristen: that's really cool.
Geza: But I like it. It's it's
Geza: It's It's so. Some something something something different, and especially we can work. So that's one of one.
Kristen: Yes. Well, that's really good. I just started, and I guess at the end of June I've been making a few different demo videos here and there a lot of like mobile phone app
Kristen: testing and stuff like that. But they asked if I wanted to do some user interviews and start
Kristen: working on videos with other people, and I was like,
Kristen: Yes,
Geza: It's it's awesome. I I have. Also, I have a iphone. I'm using iphone. But the other thing, you know, like um, the iphone is is different, but I also. But my computers are all of them are windows right, but I don't have android iphone just I for
Kristen: right. So do you use voiceover for the iphone,
Kristen: you and and and of course the main thing is voice over. Yes,
Kristen: thanks,
Kristen: do you? Uh,
Kristen: uh! Is there like a lot of differences between voice over and jaws? For?
Kristen: Oh, totally different. Yes, definitely so. Uh, most of it is much easier to use. And uh, so i'm using it uh with the finger gestures. But the jaws is story, so we can't use jaws as the gestures we've just we have to use for the cable, and for the short pockets
Kristen: it's totally totally different, and sometimes that's like for the tables we have to use like one to three for four or five fingers at the same time.
Kristen: So you know, like like a when I'm using the iphone is totally different. Is one one fingers, two fingers.
Kristen M: Wow: Yeah. Using five different fingers for tables, you said,
Kristen: Yeah, yeah, for example, I have to use all control, right? So you know what I mean with tables I have. Both of my my hands are occupied,
Kristen: so that on the phone is not like that. No, no,
Kristen: right. Do you? Do you use your phone more than your laptop just for like kind of
Kristen: i'm using phone. I just can the text, you know, like scale the or, for example, if I want to pick up some colors, even my my any kind of dress for my color, and then I also use the iphone. So the iphone it is for, for I would say like for everyday use,
Kristen: right, for for example. And then I want to check out different scenarios, even on the street, or let's see, like if I just was someone and check out some something. I also use the iphone because I can make a picture, and then it says, What is what is on the scenery? See what is there, and then any kind of object, it can recognize the object. It's also very helpful if I want to to check a different Let's see, like
Geza: the jars of can of different products. I also use the iphone for scanning. So so most of the time i'm using for everyday use the iphone.
Kristen: Nice, do you? Is that an app like, do you seeing Ai or another?
Kristen: Yes, yeah, yeah. And the that is the latest that it's called and visual is is much better than uh than I would say like uh uh, seeing that it's much more sophisticated. That's it like I would say, like there is like eight hundred different colors.
Geza: It can recognize it
nine hundred and eighty different colors.
Kristen: Oh, wow! You know what I mean in and even for the subject Recognition, like the algorithms, are the I think, the All the the algorithms are more and more sophisticated.
Kristen: Hey?
Kristen: Okay, it's called and envisioned.
Geza: Yes, and vision. And it is the free. Software And i'm gonna I don't want it from I from I'm using, but for I
Kristen: nice Okay.
Geza: But the envision actually it is uh the original. It is like it is a uh a a eyeglass, and then they can hook it up so. Any brand the the envision er
eyeglass on when they turn their head. It says what is right in the area,
Kristen: What is in the area, right? So what what they did they have? They make this this software ambition for iphone use the
Kristen: that's that's really good. I'm sure they did that for free. That's awesome, because I know that the glass things can be pretty expensive.
Kristen: It's very expensive, because yes, yes,
it's the same thing. So like the same idea, except, you know, like the form you you have to use this phone
Geza: color scenery
Kristen M: nice. I'm gonna download that and take a look at it because I used Ah, oh, it's probably like three years ago, or something. It's probably changed a lot since then. But I use the scene. One: Yeah, yes, yes,
Kristen: it's more sophisticated. Thanks. I'm glad they're making better, more progress with stuff like that. It's good,
Geza: much, much, much better,
more sophisticated.
Kristen: Okay, I'm going to download that and check it out after this.
Kristen: Um, We are almost out of time. So
Kristen: it's a pleasure. Thank you so much for sharing. Oh, you better, I hope I'm going to be sometimes in the future.
Kristen: Yeah, yeah, I hope so. Hopefully, i'll be doing more user interviews, and it's been really
Kristen: Yeah.
Kristen: Well, I hope it not. It just started raining here, So maybe it's going to be Saturday or someday.
It looks like, you know,
but it's getting cooler every morning is cooler and cooler.
Kristen: Yeah, in the mornings it's been cool. It's pretty hot here still in the afternoon's like in a weird, weird place in Caterbro. I feel like we we get the worst of the heat and the snow.
Geza: I I used to race in Beta Guru I was. I was running that it was very early, and the one time I did the uh uh cycle increase. It was very heavy. So so I was there just to do different events. But I like,
Kristen: Yeah, that's good. They've added a lot of different, like bike trails and and bike lanes and stuff, too. So that's been.
Kristen: It was participated in several years ago in those events.
Kristen: Oh, nice! That's good I did. We used to go to the Y and go swimming like twice a week.
Kristen: Yeah, it's for for the pandemic, but it should probably do that
Kristen: in total. I I I went many times to Bimc. We had always running training on Saturday mornings during the winter time we we used to go to the atmosphere a lot.
Kristen: This
Geza: what I like it. That's the that. What can we do? Nice,
Kristen: Yeah,
Kristen: Something to do
Kristen: It's
Kristen: okay. I I will let you go so you can continue on with your day. But thank you very much.
Geza: Thank you very much, and I hope you will have a great week.
Kristen: Yeah, you, too. I'm actually going to Toronto later this week to meet Kate for the first time. So
Kristen: you will enjoy it for sure.
Kristen: Thank you. I'm looking forward to it.
Kristen: Have a good day.
Kristen: Okay, have a great day. Have a great day. Thank you so much,
Kristen: hey?
Geza: Thank you. Bye, bye, bye,
Geza: and all that for all the refresh stories. But November at this pageholder for desktop, hold open tart, hold it for a meeting, a leave, meeting their feedback, only a button.